i'm afraid that um romanian garrison in
mario poll they don't really have very
many options um it's according to all
reports that one's hearing they're
running very short of ammunition and i
think the ukrainian forces generally
are not able to resupply them
so uh i think it's only a matter of time
before mario paul completely falls under
russian control um as we heard over the
weekend the russians did offer some kind
of surrender option which the ukrainian
forces have chosen not to accept so i
i'm afraid um this is going to be
a
very gruesome um
and sad end to an heroic fight by those
ukrainian soldiers but it's going to end
i think probably sooner rather than
later with mario paul completely falling
under russian control and then of course
the russians would have achieved one of
their strategic objectives which is that
land corridor from crimea through mario
paul to the donbass region
uh lord dana you think it could fall
within the next few days i understand
from what you said and and this then
sets up that contiguous land corridor
that the russians have been looking for
just explain to our viewers uh what that
will mean for the russian forces and
their prosecution of this war going
forward
well securing a land corridor from
crimea which viewers will remember was
seized by russia
in 2014
but crimea hitherto has been only
accessible to the russians by sea
now that they have almost completed
seizing a land corridor
from crimea through mario paul to the
donbass region which of course links
with russia proper they will then have
joined up the dots if you like between
crimea and russia proper but in a sense
this is
something of a sideshow now although an
important one and an important strategic
objective of the russians and what we're
really what we should be focusing on
is the russian likely significant attack
uh from the east pushing west to secure
the two provinces of luhanskan diets
and the and the shelling that's been
widely reported over the last few days
right across
ukraine i think one has to see that as
being part of a preliminary operation by
the russians prior to launching their
ground defensive uh in the east
uh and lordanna i wonder if you can
react as well uh this morning we've
heard of at least five missile strikes
on leve that's of course in the west of
ukraine it's a place where many people
have fled to on their way out of the
country what does that tell us do you
think about perhaps the change in tempo
of the russian invasion
well i think what that does tell us
is that the
russian attack in the east that i was
talking about just a moment ago
is being properly prepared for this time
what we saw right at the start of this
conflict that uh strike haphazard strike
south from belarus towards kiev was a
very uncoordinated operation which as we
all know
ultimately failed
vladimir putin has put general alexander
vornikov uh in charge of operations uh
in ukraine and he is preparing this
major strike in the east striking from
the east towards the west
and as part of the preliminary
operations for that ground maneuver
we're seeing artillery strikes across
the length and breadth of
of ukraine even as far to the western
city of of lev
now
this is for two two reasons one is
probably to continue to try and
undermine the will of the ukrainian
people i think that'll be largely
unsuccessful as their spirit is is quite
fantastic but secondly i think the
russians are
targeting
military hardware depots factories and
trying to erode and reduce the
capability of the ukrainian armed forces
to resist their strike when it comes in
the east so i think we see the cruise
missile strikes the artillery strikes
right across ukraine as being part of
the
the softening up if you like the
preliminary operations before the major
land strike which will occur
sometime in the next few days or weeks
yeah and obviously the west is where any
resupply of ukrainian forces will be
coming in from so there are some high
value targets there for the russians to
hear
now
richard danner i wonder if we can just
pick up a little bit so i know it's
slightly out of your area but i will
hope that you have a thought on this uh
boris johnson's been banned from going
to russia we've heard vladimir zelinsky
saying that
depending on how mario paul plays out
for his fighters that'll be the end of
any uh negotiations with russia i wonder
how would we even get into the
the possibility of having ceasefire
negotiations at this stage with someone
like vladimir putin is prosecuting the
war in this kind of way
well you asked a very good question and
i think
early in the conflict
i think there were very reasonable hopes
that sooner rather than later and this
of course hasn't happened
that both parties would realize that
neither was going to achieve their
military objectives very quickly and
that some form of ceasefire leading to a
peace agreement could be could be
arrived at by negotiations and both the
israelis and the turks are trying to
facilitate such conversations which
really have got have got nowhere
i think we have to accept that this is
not going to be a conflict that's ended
in days and weeks it's going to be a
conflict that grinds on
for
months and possibly years
both sides have now
lost too many civilians too many
military
deaths to easily and quickly get up
to give up the ukrainians desperately uh
want to continue the fight and and be
successful and vladimir putin has got to
have some kind of success that he can
report to his people so i think what
we're going to see going back to what i
said a few moments ago
is having achieved that land corridor
from crimea to the donbass we're then
going to see this
meticulously prepared i think this time
attack by the
russians into the donbass region to
secure those two provinces and then
threaten to move further west
and i'm afraid that the russians having
captured those areas in the east having
captured that land corridor will not
want to give that up and it may well be
that over the time ukraine may have to
accept that it's lost part of its
territory russia will not easily give up
that territory and frankly why should it
who can make them do so and nato is not
going to make to mount a major operation
and throw them out and if the ukrainians
can't and it may well be an ask too far
for the ukrainians to throw the russians
out then this may well become a
stalemate
um over a period of months and years
whereby the russians have controlled the
east have controlled that land corridor
and the ukrainians are left with about
85 percent of their territory that may
be where over time this thing will wind
up